for the first leg of my journey I'm
leaving behind Berlin favilla Bud Essen
in the German countryside once a world
leader in industry and innovation when
it comes to digitalization Germany is
lagging far behind
despite the impending arrival of 5g
network technology here in Germany in
some parts of the country especially in
the countryside people are still
dreaming of 3G networks and a reliable
internet connection let's not forget it
wasn't so long ago that the German
Chancellor Angela Merkel herself was
described in the Internet as new
territory agriculture is just one
industry feeling the effects of
Germany's digital shortcomings like here
in villa Radisson where networked dead
zones are a common occurrence for
farmers like Olaf flick by using GPS
signals this tractor has the capacity to
drive itself autonomously and cover the
exact same route in the exact same
tracks taken on previous days
because I'm how do you appeal this value
here shows how good reception is you
have to imagine it's like when you get
LTE 3G or E on your phone the higher
these numbers become the worse the
reception gets right now as we stand we
can work with one centimeter accuracy
but when the signal fails things go a
little off plan and the tractors wheels
veer off course which means wasted
resources and expenditure for farmers
what's most important here for these
farmers is precision and making sure
that they confirm with exact signals and
making sure that these signals are even
available in the first place so that
they can work more precisely and
efficiently to make sure that they don't
waste any use of the land farm owner
Bernhard fly-half on Vice is holding the
German government to its pledge of
nationwide high-speed Internet by 2025
and 5g mobile internet politicians must
establish these standards across the
board network operators who can provide
5g standards must be obliged to make
this internet connection available not
only in the densely populated high
revenue regions but also in the
countryside where the turnover is loved
the German government has now promised
plenty of measures to at least get
Germany on the way when it comes to
digitalization but now the question is
whether those measures can really be
implemented in time to make sure that
Germany has any chance at all of
becoming a digital tech giant well Kate
Brady you saw her there she's now with
us here in the studio to talk a little
bit more about this and Kate you know we
just have to tell our viewers that a
couple of months ago Germany's research
minister said the following 5g is not
necessarily at every milk-can it turns
out though that the people in those
areas they really took that quite
differently than perhaps it was intended
for listen yeah they really are
frustrated and the two guys I spoke to
there in the report that you've just
seen actually quoted Germany's research
minister themselves as well and this is
something that really struck them and I
think there is still quite a blasé
attitude not only from some politicians
but also from some other Germans in
different parts of Germany who aren't
experiencing this lack of network every
day of course
this report here that I followed was
actually just focusing on agriculture
but also this affects their entire lives
what when what about when an emergency
doctor doesn't have a signal on their
phone so that they can't take an
emergency call for example so this
really gets into every part of the
everyday lives especially in rural
Germany and it's just one of the many
issues actually that is concerning
Germans right now we know that you're
actually doing a series on that
particular topic so what else is on the
agenda
exactly they'll be running every day
this week so we saw a digitalization
today tomorrow we've got Japanese
housing crisis demographic change the
fact that Germany is becoming older and
that's affecting the workforce
especially and then also climate change
to end that series how could CERN do to
voters seem about these issues and and
especially in these towns that you
visited I mean you visited a lot of
small towns in the country didn't you
exactly and it was not only issues that
are in the countryside but these are
issues are concerning all of Germany and
I think that's what's quite unique about
these issues that it isn't something
that's that's individual to just one
specific group of people or one specific
place you know even where here in the
German capital in Berlin and even here
if we take the example of network
coverage today you know you can be in
the center of the German capital and not
have any internet connection not have
any phone connection and this is
something that you hear from voters when
you ask if they're concerned they are
concerned because they keep hearing
these promises from politicians and now
they want to see some action taken
though and of course we could see the
repercussions of that playing out later
this year we have some really important
state elections coming up in Germany as
well and Germans really are becoming
frustrated especially at the government
that we currently have here the grand
coalition between the Conservatives and
the Social Democrats and these really
are issues that are going to shape
Germany's future okay I'm so a lot to
look forward to Kate Brady thank you so
much